la crise de la vache folle jean glavany
le ministre de l'agriculture recevra les
syndicats agricoles la semaine prochaine
des organisations déçu pour l'instant
par les mesures d' aide à la filière
bovine
résultat les actions de protestations se
sont multipliées ce vendredi céline
crespy
les éleveurs de bovins multiplient leurs
mouvements un peu partout en france 400
professionnels ont arpenté en fin de
matinée les rues du mans pour protester
contre le plan daide à la filière bovine
m'est arrivé aux grilles de la
préfecture la manifestation dégénère et
c'est à coups de grenades lacrymogènes
et de lances à eau que les forces de
l'ordre ripostent alençon dans l'orne le
nom de code de la mobilisation et l
opération rosbif dès 5h30 du matin 200
éleveurs envahissent là encore la
préfecture des tracteurs bloquent
l'entrée du bâtiment un marché aux
bestiaux est organisée si ce geste est
symbolique l'inquiétude des éleveurs
elle est bien réelle
j'suis des cours baisse de la
consommation du boeuf d'après la fnsea à
la fin de l'année la france comptera 50
milles 7 de bétail en stock et le plan
daide annoncée par le gouvernement et
pour les éleveurs largement insuffisant
dans les mesures qu'ont annoncé alors
que ce soit j'ose pas la semaine
dernière que je sois glavany en début de
semaine il ya véritablement tromperie
sur la sur la marchandise annoncé 3
milliards de francs pour sauver
l'élevage bovin alors qu'il aurait
probablement besoin de dix milliards en
réalité est qu en fait simplement 4 à
500 millions seront à destination des
éleveurs
c'est véritablement se fout de la gueule
des éleveurs autre style autre
mobilisation à nantes les éleveurs s'en
réfère à la justice après la
confédération paysanne c'est la
coordination rurale qui a déposé pas
moins de 500 plaintes contre x
reçu par le procureur de la république
ces éleveurs souhaitent désormais
remonter la filière pourrait établir les
responsabilités de chacun
il